-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian whose stand-up special
"Ms. Pat: Y'all want to hear
something crazy?"
is available on Netflix.
She also created and stars
in "The Ms. Pat Show."
The second season is streaming
now on BET+.
Let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell her she pretty.
-What?
-[Bleep] you.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
That's why you're dead [bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Please welcome back to the show
Ms. Pat, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
I'm in person this time.
-You're in person.
We had you on Zoom last time,
which was fantastic,
but it's the real deal today,
and we're very excited.
-It's the real deal.
-I got to see you in person
at the Emmys.
Your show was nominated for
Best Directing for a Sitcom.
-Yes. I was so excited.
I could not believe
I was at the Emmys.
I wasn't -- You know, I didn't
need the dust collector
'cause the, director was up
for nomination.
I call the little trophy
the dust collector.
-Oh, gotcha.
-I was there for the food,
and it was great.
-It was good food.
You were also at -- Norman Lear,
the incredible television writer
and producer who's made,
you know, so many iconic shows
over the years, he just had a
100th birthday party celebration
that you were at.
What was your experience
with Norman?
-You know, the party was running
a little late for me.
So I'm usually in bed by 8:30
when I'm home.
So when I got up to speak,
I was like,
"Norman Lear, how you still
awake? You 100 and I'm 50."
[ Laughter ]
"I know these people got
a battery pack in you.
Are you still alive, Mr. Lear?"
[ Laughter ]
-But it must've been so cool
that he's a fan of your show.
-It was cool, but it was also
cool to see
a 100-year-old person
up past 8:30.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That's his real accomplishment.
-That's his real accomplishment.
'Cause I'm 50, and 8:30,
I'm out.
[ Laughter ]
I take this wig and this bra off
and it's over.
[ Laughter ]
-It's good that it's not
time-released at 8:30,
and then if you're out
in public, that'd be --
-Oh, it is time-released.
[ Laughter ]
-You pull from your life
in your wonderful sitcom.
You have eight kids.
You have three grandkids.
How do they feel about the fact
that your show
is a little bit
autobiographical?
-You know, they all excited,
but I have four kids
that somebody gave to me.
I'm not gonna say I adopted them
'cause somebody dropped them off
and said,
"These are your crack babies."
[ Laughter ]
And so I never adopted
anybody's kids.
They always give 'em to me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And they don't never come
insured, either.
[ Laughter ]
So, the new babies
that I'm raising,
they're a little bougie.
They come up to me one day
and they said,
"We Googled you and we're rich."
I said, "Get those dirty drawers
and let's wash our underwear."
[ Laughter ]
"Ain't nobody rich
in this house.
We all do the same thing."
-Yeah, you can't let 'em --
You can't let kids start
thinking there's money to spend.
-Oh, you can't let anybody think
there's money to spend.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you have that problem with
your family?
-Yeah. I have a brother
who told me
I should invest in his tow truck
company.
But I was like, "You just got
out of federal penitentiary.
You got a leg monitor."
You can't tow no trucks.
You can't go past the mailbox."
[ Laughter ]
"You need a better investment,
brother."
-When they come to you with
their investment ideas,
do you ever try to point them in
another direction?
-No. I'm honest.
I tell people, I said,
I didn't give you --
You know I'm an ex-drug dealer.
"I didn't give you
my crack-dealing money.
I used to forge white people
checks.
I didn't give you
none of that money."
Black people keep starting
their checking accounts over.
"And I'm not gonna give you
any of my TV money."
[ Laughter ]
-So that's good.
You just laid down the law
early.
-I say no. "I'm not gonna give
you nothing.
Go get a job."
-But this is very nice.
Is it true that you encouraged
your husband to retire?
-Yes. After the first season,
I lived in Indiana.
I'm from Atlanta,
and I wanted to go home,
and I told my husband,
"I'm never coming back.
You need to retire."
-Yeah.
-And so now, he's just doing
foolish stuff,
and I still wish he had his job.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it backfired a little bit?
Did it backfire?
-He just buying toys.
He bought a $4,000 drone that --
we both 50 -- don't know
how to fly it,
and it gets stuck in the air.
And I'm like,
"Just hit it with a rock."
[ Laughter ]
-So he's not really good with
sort of gadgets.
-No, not technology.
Now, he can build you a house
or he can build you a doghouse.
But he don't know nothing about
electronics.
And he always blame it on
"I can't see. I need glasses."
No, you don't.
You're too old for technology.
[ Laughter ]
-This is very exciting
'cause season two is airing.
Season three is done.
-Season three is done.
-You've got
a stand-up special out
and you're going on the road.
Do you feel like,
with all this success,
is your fan base is changing?
-My fan base actually got black.
-What?
-I'm real-real black.
You can see that, right?
Well, not real-real black,
Wesley Snipes black,
but I'm black.
[ Laughter ]
I'm culturally black, okay?
For years, I did Joe Rogan,
Bert Kreischer, all of that,
you know, white stuff,
let's be honest.
And when I did BET+,
the black people are like,
"Oh, my God. You're my aunty."
I'm like, "Where was y'all at
when I needed y'all?"
[ Laughter ]
But I love the diversity that I
bring that I can talk about,
"Hi, I grew up and where I'm
from in Atlanta."
And no matter what your race is,
everybody can relate.
-I think everybody can relate,
especially to the struggle,
and I think people are really
excited excited when they
see you because they understand
how you worked so hard.
And obviously, you've got this
natural talent,
but I don't think any any of it
would've happened without...
-Being shot
-...this incredible work ethic.
-Being in jail,
having kids young.
I needed a little struggle.
-But I want to say,
you've got grandkids now.
You must thrive
as a grandmother.
Do they love you?
-I do.
I have twin grandsons,
one cute, one ugly.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I just said that
on national TV.
-Well, you didn't say which one
was which, so they don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Don't name names.
-You know what's crazy?
One of them is really ugly.
But he --
[ Laughter ]
And she gave -- What's so crazy?
I hate people that give me
newborn pictures.
So she gives me pictures of them
when they a baby, and I'm like,
"I'm not putting this mess
on my wall."
[ Laughter ]
"Come back in eight months
when they stop looking like
whatever this is."
[ Laughter ]
-It's very nice to have someone
both loving and honest
in your life.
-One of my grandsons
look like he smoke weed.
[ Laughter ]
-How old is he?
-Five.
[ Laughter ]
But he look like
my side of the family.
I'm like,
"Baby, you never did alcohol,
but you took on
an alcoholic face."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's a lovely thing
to pass down to your kids.
Hey, I'm so happy you're here.
-Thank you.
-It is just such a pleasure
to see you in person.
And congratulations on
all your success.
You guys --
-Thank you.
-Ms. Pat.
Season two of "The Ms. Pat Show"
is streaming now on BET+.
We'll be right back.